[Applause]
this is big
the the jake paul asked him oh i know
the fight was big everything else sucked
oh no
the trailer event was horrible that's my
point was
absolutely horrible um we can get into
why it's horrible later
uh or we could just talk about it now
it's too much music and the fight the
fights were boring before the jake paul
one and then too much music like i don't
care about watching sweetie lip sync
okay
i don't care about doji cat i don't care
about any of these things fight fans are
not
dozier cat fans they're not sweetie fans
justin bieber's performance i thought
was good
i could do one song do one song
shots of c's where's daniel caesar yeah
bring out daniel
daniel caesar the [ __ ] peaches and
then get to the fights
all we need are the fights we don't care
about the music component at all um i'm
gonna give you guys
one bit of push back i hated it i'm also
not a fight fan but this wasn't market
to fight fans
that's a good point this is marketed two
young people who would be interested in
jake paul fighting
they [ __ ] up my issue is the
performances weren't good
like sweetie wasn't what are you doing
they can't be good like even
super bowl performances you're like man
i'm all right and that is the biggest
performance ever you're watching a music
video live
and music videos at home are okay
yeah live you're like what the [ __ ] are
we doing empty stadium
stadium was weird you were in the room
for a concert
i could see that as potentially being
good but you're not you're watching at
home so
one song is kind of fun bake it into the
intro in some way
figure out something but it was just too
long like it's one o'clock by the time
the [ __ ] fight comes yeah
so bad job but i think trailer will be
able to adjust and they'll go
okay people could not give a flying [ __ ]
about this much music
maybe we'll have a couple music acts
because i'm looking at this like you
wasted money you had to pay all these
people you don't need to pay him you
don't need charlie dimelio and
dixie demelio giving people fake belts
not necessary
yeah what people are invested in when it
comes to a fight
is literally the outcome of that fight
yeah that's all they do they don't need
the theatrics around it they need none
of that
when we watch a street fight you know
who did this brilliantly bar stool when
they did rough and rowdy
they knew that they weren't going to
have famous people fight each other but
what they could do is create rivalries
so they had the city kid versus the
country bumpkin right the gay dude
versus the straight dude
yeah right the this frat versus this rat
a firefighter versus a policeman
they found built-in rivalries that
already existed
and now we're emotionally connected to
the outcome of that fight i want to see
who wins the
the older brother the younger brother
they had an older brother younger
brother fight each other once i just
watched it on youtube like why am i
watching this
yeah i want to see if that younger
brother can get him yeah right and it
was brilliant because they understood
the emotional driving point of a fight
jake paul also understands that yeah and
that's why we tuned into that fight yeah
and ben askren also understands yes
and that's why we tuned into that fight
yeah and i [ __ ] love ben and i want
to talk about ben
afterwards and uh but i first want to
give
uh jake some flowers yeah let's not even
talk about the knockout just yet
jake paul is the
biggest fight in boxing right now
bigger than canelo yeah bigger than
tyson fury
bigger than anthony joshua he is right
now the biggest fight in boxing i know
you guys think i'm absolutely [ __ ]
[ __ ] when i say this
yes i'm not joking 1.5 million
pay-per-view buys
1.5 million i don't think you're crazy i
just need to hear numbers
1.5 million pay-per-view bias we can
look at other past pay-per-views but
here's the thing you got to consider
this one got 1.5 million pay-per-view
buys now that he knocked
askren out in the first round yeah
people who don't like jake paul
have just increased exponentially
and jake knows that and the mma
community that's infuriated with jake
paul
has increased exponentially literally
every fighter
after their fight robert whittaker said
i'd fight jake paul for less than
500 000 why are you mentioning that
fight
why you even bring it up you just won a
fight on the same night he is under
everybody's skin
and what do i always say on this podcast
haters and celebrators pay the same
price of admission and this guy
is gonna take people hating on him yeah
and ride that [ __ ] to the [ __ ] top
now
i keep hearing people say this all the
[ __ ] time they go why isn't he
fighting a real boxer
why is he fighting a real boxer why
would he why would he
why does he have to he's not trying to
win the belt he doesn't want to be the
greatest
boxer yes money money and you cannot
show me a boxer that wouldn't like to
make millions of dollars in their first
three fights
you think that these boxers want to
fight 20 times before they fight for a
title and maybe
touch a million dollars yeah [ __ ] no
give me the money immediately
if you're smart enough to not care about
the [ __ ] belt which is
it which if you don't care about the
sport
who gives a [ __ ] about the best yeah
right if there was no money in boxing
jake paul's not gonna be a boxer
right he knows it but that [ __ ]
say what you want about i don't care if
you like his personality or don't like
his personality
remove personality from all this right
just look at straight business
the guy knows how to get under people's
skin get them invested and get them
wanting to beat his ass
he's really smart the kid is [ __ ]
smart
he's really smart he understands
business he might not um
communicate it well but he knows what
he's doing bro he knows what he knows
how to get people to [ __ ] hate him
and in an attention economy
hate is the easiest form of attention we
are so much quicker to hate things than
we are love
yes how hard is it for us to give
something up being hated
takes less talent but it takes one
supreme talent and that is you are
you have to be willing to be hated super
pop which most of us are not superpower
again i don't care if you're listening
right now you're like i [ __ ] hate
that kid jake paul i don't care
yeah he's gonna make tens of millions of
dollars
doing this boxing thing because you hate
him you probably already made
tens of millions and just for numbers
sake you said 1.5 media
or million pay-per-view advise if that's
a true number that would make it the
12th
highest paper uh pay-per-view box ever
ever ever and that's comparing to the
floyd mayweather fights this is more
than
tyson fights like this is number 12 in
like with the adverts
so this is the biggest name in boxing
right now whether you like it or not and
he's not even fighting the elite boxing
guys
if him and conor square off go go i mean
that could be
that could be the number one fight so
listen if conor beats doesn't pour you
yeah if conor beats dustin and
doesn't fight jake he is
wasting money yeah he's literally taking
money lighting on fire
because that is the biggest money fight
he can get yeah whether conor likes it
or not the biggest money fight he can
get
is against jake paul yeah i mean
it is unbelievable what this kid has
[ __ ] done yeah
you might hate him and have a reason to
he's already back starting beef
he's already tweeting i think they
released some footage of mike perry
and him sparring mike perry platinum
like there is a ufc fighter yeah
yeah and he wanted to give uh some work
to jake
and then jake i guess tweeted something
or said something about how like you
know mike perry admitted that i kicked
his ass or whatever now mike perry's
all upset mike perry's trying to get
into it are they upset or are they
excited that he's throwing them in there
and now they want to see if they can get
their shot maybe
either way because it's it's a win for
mike perry to get to fight jay paul
even if he loses and this is the and i
don't know if his team is doing this i
don't know if he's doing i always give
credit to the person who's uh takes the
responsibility but like
maybe it's all them but what you do is
you let them all compete
yeah who can stir up the most [ __ ]
yeah and whoever stirs up the most [ __ ]
this is what the ufc does very well
right they have rankings but if you stir
up a lot of [ __ ]
you get some fights yeah kevin holland
was stirring up [ __ ]
kevin got some fights now he lost him
but he was throwing it up and he gets
rewarded
so what you do is you throw names out
there you throw an eight diaz out there
you throw a platinum mike perry out
there you throw tyson fury's
little brother i forget his name he's
got another fury
you throw his name out there you throw
five six seven guys out there conor of
course
and you see who gets the most you see
what the market
dictates and not only the market you see
what they do with it
yeah yeah right if so if the market
doesn't want it but you create the
market
yeah fair enough all of a sudden now
we're cooking right
like when logan and mayweather were
gonna fight the market wasn't that
interested
so they pulled it back and they're like
okay we need to generate some interest
yeah this [ __ ] jake has
generated interest yeah because he's
willing and that's what he has that uh
logan is great but what he has that
logan doesn't have is jake is willing
to be hated he doesn't give a [ __ ] logan
is captain america
yeah dude logan is is captain america
and he wants
people to like him and i get that
because he's likable yeah and he plays a
good good guy he's seems like he made
one huge mistake and other than that he
seems like a pretty good kid
yeah and i i actually
i actually don't mind having the
brothers be one good guy one heel
that's how it should be it it it might
be the way to do it because if you're
otherwise if you're jake
you are in your big brother's shadow
your entire life you're just not him
what's the only way to be different is
he's the heel if he's captain america
let me go all the way heal
especially if you're looking at logan
you're like he's really good at being
likeable
he's really good at being like and
you're like i don't know if i can do
that yeah but i can be different i can
be weird
i can be antagonistic i can't troll
right and
the [ __ ] found a way within his
third fight to make
millions of dollars you show me another
boxer table to do this you cannot
regardless if you like it or not he is
the biggest name in boxing in terms of
money yeah and you know who made belts
worthless
the [ __ ] sanctioning bodies that
threw out a million different belts
for every single weight you made the
belts worthless don't be upset at jake
paul yeah be upset at yourselves
you took away all the value when you
kept handing it out you was like a fiat
currency
yeah we don't care about opr currency
over the dogs get slaughtered you got to
you gotta try to grab cash everywhere
this belt that belt that but son isaac
as a guy who casually watches
i have no clue what any belt means yeah
i barely know the weight classes and i
know why those have to exist but like
multiple belts for a weight class i'm
out i don't give a [ __ ] i'm out
so regardless if you think that he can
box or not you cannot deny he has power
yes ben oscar has been hit incredibly
hard by people who hit
incredibly hard yes and jake paul
hit him and he was concussed
while he was standing it was because he
went down
i mean i assume it's concussion right
anytime lights go out right so
and don't get me wrong asking the tough
[ __ ] got back up and
said he was ready to go the referee
stopped it i'm not mad at that stop but
the point is he hit him with one shot
and put him down
tko is multiple shots eventually like i
can't take anymore
one shot lights out power is a natural
thing
sometimes people have it sometimes they
don't have there are professional boxers
that we all love that don't have one
shot knockout power
yeah it's just what it is and they've
been phenomenal fighters
and there are guys that we might have
never heard of that have incredible one
punch concussive power yeah say what you
want about jake he has power
right lights out go you don't you're not
mad at the early stoppage
no no why because this is
now you could be mad as a consumer
because you want blood but
in my mind i think that he got hurt
enough he was out on his feet
the way that his body fell it looked
like he was at his feet now ashton's
toughest [ __ ] nails he's gonna get up
i don't think you need to put him
through that when like this is not his
future this nice career
a short stoppage really affects a
fighter who wants to keep fighting in
their career
because you stole a win from him ask her
into this for money
right the guy was [ __ ] brilliant in
the in the lead up to this like
not only was he generating all this
interest in the fight
the guy was doing so many promos yeah
like i bet
he maybe made just as much fighting as
he did in promos
a few minutes before the fight he posted
a video of him hitting this punching
machine
in his own locker room yeah cash the
check so like
you you for me if i'm a ref in that
situation i'm going this guy is doing
this for fun
and for a huge payday it's not worth him
getting knocked down
again and really doing damage because
that's when the damage happens yeah
so i'm not upset that i don't think
people like oh this was rigged this was
rigged
look at the punch connect it's not
written you know what and i don't know
you can tell me if the form was off or
not but before he landed a punch
he threw another overhand right that
barely missed and that one i was like
he almost knocked him the [ __ ] out right
same combo sit and then got him 10
seconds later i guess same combo but
i was like oh this kid has power when i
saw that punch miss i was like [ __ ]
say what you want about about jake he
made an adjustment in the ring this is
in the first round of
fight oscar lands the first punch of the
fight yeah
jake kind of rushes in ascertain dips
and then hits him with an overhand right
i don't think there was much on it but
jake gets caught
he's a little bit cautious and as asrin
starts to plot forward
he made an adjustment which was really
[ __ ] impressive
he started throwing this hook as aspirin
came in
so ashton comes in he's got his hands
kind of in front of him a little bit
more yeah
so jake would throw this hook as he came
in and he caught him a few times
and that stopped askran from coming in
as um
bravely for lack of a better word
because he knew that there was a cost
for coming in
and i'm telling you to make an
adjustment in real time like that i've
i've
i've logged a lot of hours sparring okay
and when you're in the heat of the
moment you're not thinking okay what can
i do different like sometimes between
rounds you're like i was getting caught
with that how do i avoid that [ __ ] a
little bit like that
and as you do more you maybe get a
little more comfortable making those
adjustments
it was impressive i'm not saying the guy
should go
challenge for the [ __ ] cruiserweight
belt right now yeah
but three years in it's impressive
and the last thing he should do is fight
some boxer that's really good that has
no [ __ ] clout
he should go after mma guys and he
should stay in that world and people who
are famous
stay in that world cash the [ __ ]
checks yeah i think
yeah if he had 1.5 million buys on this
one to get from number 12 to number
three which is khabib connor
you need one more billion views and
you're talking someone like connor
an international audience can i tell you
they're so close to being number one the
the other ones let me tell you something
if jake paul fights conor mcgregor
you're gonna think i'm crazy when i say
this
it's the biggest fight in history bigger
than floyd and connor
the two biggest are the number one is
4.6 million
pacquiao mayweather second biggest is
mayweather uh
mcgregor 4.3 million push back then it
goes down to 2.5 million which was
khabib mcgregor let me take this back
let me take this back
i take that back i apologize
i don't think they hit mayweather
pacquiao and i don't think they hit
mayweather mcgregor
i think they can beat the 2.5 i agreed
because you're adding conor star power
to it
i mean like and conor's got to win this
fight against poirier to make that
happen
but if he wins that fight against
poirier he's going in there
he could go in there with jake and they
could do 2.5
easy easy
if conor loses what happens he loses a
lot of money
he loses a lot of money we were calling
sports bars this weekend
they wouldn't even pay for the
pay-per-view like this was really driven
i think
by the attention of like jake paul his
audience a younger market
trailer fans you bring in you know
these bars buying these licenses for
that i don't think it was trailer fans i
literally think it was fight fans
wanting to see jake paul get knocked out
you